what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have a lot of news to talk about
today Loki is only one day away a lot of
people are super excited for the series
I am as well and a lot of people have
been wondering about any post credit
scenes it seems like Marvel has kind of
veered away from that with their Disney
plus series however I'll tell you
everything that you need to know at
least for the first four episodes we
also have some blade news that we gotta
talk about today and Marvel Studios has
finally addressed the arrest of Jonathan
Majors now this is different from before
before they addressed how integral his
role was going to be in Loki that is
something they hadn't done previously
they hadn't really talked about Jonathan
majors's role as king the Conqueror or
Victor timely or he who remains or any
variant of Nathaniel Richards AKA King
in Loki season 2. Marvel finally talked
about how important his character is in
Loki season 2 but now they have actually
talked about the literal arrest of
Jonathan majors and if that did indeed
impact Loki season 2. the answer of
which they gave was kind of surprising
but of course we'll break down
everything you need to know in this
video and a big congratulations to
YouTube user Zella 24 for being the
winner of our September giveaway that
person has been contacted and of course
our October giveaway has started all you
got to do to enter subscribe and leave a
comment down below for your chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 to Marvel
Legends items or some DC items winner
picks one item we pick a winner at the
end of each month so first and foremost
since a lot of people have been asking
yes there is one post credit scene for
Loki season 2 and that is at the end of
episode one no spoilers here are not
gonna talk about what it is but I have
seen episodes one through four and that
is the only post credit scene two three
and four do not have a post credit scene
I am not sure about five and six since
obviously I've not seen them so they
very well could in episode 6 we hope
does because we know that the TVA is
going to be a factor in Deadpool 3 and
it's said that Owen Wilson's Mobius is
going to be in Deadpool 3 as well so
hopefully we get some sort of a teaser
for that in a post-credit scene or maybe
even a king the Conqueror teaser in that
post-credit fingers crossed for that so
stick around after the credits will
really mid credits for episode 1 and the
other episodes two through four no post
credits so like I mentioned Marvel
Studios finally addressed the actual
arrest of Jonathan majors in an
interview with variety executive
producer for Loki and Marvel Kevin
Wright was literally asked about the
arrest of Jonathan majors and how it
affected Loki season 2. in this
interview with variety they asked you
mentioned he who remains and Victor
timely you finished shooting season 2 in
2022 but did Jonathan Majors arrest for
assault and March result in any changes
to the show and this was Kevin Wright's
response no this is Maybe not maybe this
is the first Marvel series to never have
any additional photography the story
that is on the screen is the story we
set out to make we went out there with a
very specific idea of what we wanted
this to be and we found a way to tell it
in that production period it's very much
what's on screen on Disney plus now they
do say more and I have to commend Marvel
Studios big time on what we're about to
talk about but to address this this is
actually kind of contradictory to some
things that we've heard from some
insiders kind of what we heard before is
that they did actually do some
additional Photography they did shoot
more scenes and that was so perhaps if
they needed to recast Jonathan Majors as
Kang they could now that's all we really
heard when it came down to these extra
scenes that were shot they were simply a
backup plan for Marvel Studios just in
case Jonathan Majors was found guilty
and they did need to replace him however
this report is stating that they did not
do that and perhaps they actually didn't
because what they had to say next is
actually pretty impressive and
commendable on Marvel studios's behalf
after asking that first question about
Jonathan majors arrest and if it
affected the show variety then stated
it's clear that Majors plays an integral
role this season and you just alluded
that Marvel usually does additional
photography on all its titles so was
there any decision about making changes
to the show given the uncertainty about
what was happening with majors and this
was Kevin Wright's response no and that
mainly came from I know as much as you
do at the moment it felt Hasty to do
anything without knowing how all of this
plays out so basically what he just
stated was we didn't know if Jonathan
Majors was actually guilty or innocent
meaning they didn't just hear the news
and go oh crap yeah he's definitely
guilty he definitely did that he
definitely assaulted that woman we need
to get rid of him right away no they
simply said we're gonna wait and see
what the Court decides because you are
supposed to be innocent until proven
guilt T and yes at first it did look
pretty bad on Jonathan Major's behalf
however then him and his legal team came
out with a lot of evidence in favor of
him actually being innocent and the
victim of the situation but it is
unfortunate that a lot of companies did
drop Jonathan Majors his PR Company did
his management company dropped him as
well he was put off on some movies and
some commercials as well and overall his
reputation was really tarnished which
makes it hard basically to get any more
work as an actor so his whole career has
been severely affected by this entire
situation and if he is indeed innocent I
hope he can bounce back and again kudos
to Marvel Studios for waiting to see the
outcome before making a decision
obviously if he is found guilty they
will recast King the Conqueror it seems
pretty clear with what Kevin Wright said
how basically they are waiting to see
how all of this plays out if he's
innocent no changes if he's guilty
they'll recast him as king the Conqueror
it's pretty simple at this point and
they have put him in some promotions for
the show no he's not in there a ton but
he is still in some of these promotions
and featurettes because he is a really
really big part of some of the episodes
in Loki season 2. and I think a lot of
people are gonna be real surprised by
his character now as I mentioned in the
beginning we do have some blade news but
it's not exactly good news or depending
on how you look at it it could actually
be good news let me explain according to
The Insider Daniel rpk the blade script
is being Rewritten again if you don't
remember or you didn't hear about it in
the first place the original blade
script was being Rewritten by Marvel
Studios because apparently it really
wasn't very good and the hershla Ali was
very unsatisfied with the script but
luckily Marvel Studios decided hey let's
rewrite it if it's not that good if our
main actor doesn't like it and it's not
really being received that well by our
staff let's just go ahead and rewrite it
kudos to them for doing that but kudos
to them for rewriting it again if Daniel
rpk's report is accurate now again this
could be viewed as good or bad it could
be be bad that they simply can't get the
script right however it's not the
easiest thing to write a script and make
a great movie it does take time and a
lot of work and sometimes the Pieces
Just Don't Fall together with the story
that you're trying to create so it is
unfortunate that they have to rewrite
the script again however it's good news
because they're only going to rewrite it
if they think the story was bad so
rather than putting out a bad script and
a bad movie they're making the necessary
changes to make a good blade movie so
more kudos to Marvel Studios it's great
that they waited until the actual trial
results to determine what to do with
Jonathan Majors as came to conqueror
instead of just firing him like some
other people did when this news broke
out and good for them for being willing
to rewrite a script not once not twice
but however many times really it takes
to make a good script and make a good
movie and a lot of people are really
excited for blade and the more
Supernatural side of the MCU so this is
in my opinion at least very good news I
would always choose a rewrite over a
mediocre movie but let let me know your
thoughts about everything that we talked
about in this video in the comments down
below and let me know how excited you
are for Loki season 2. don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
as well and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof